what do back doors ransomware catfishing
extortion and exploitation have in
common they are some of the top trends
we identified in this year's X-Force
threat intelligence index
attackers followed the money and right
now persistent access to corporate
environments go for a lot of money on
the dark web making back doors a
profitable commodity for attackers
representing 21 percent of cases back
doors which are malware offering
attackers remote access to compromise
systems were the most common action
observed in incidents in 2022 knocking
out ransomware which held the top spot
since 2020. attackers often use back
doors or persistent access to execute
ransomware attacks
unless more businesses put their
defenses on the offense today's backdoor
problem will turn into tomorrow's
ransomware crisis
representing 17 percent of attacks
worldwide ransomware was the second most
common action observed in 2022 an exor
study revealed that while there's been a
slight decline in the prevalence of
ransomware a taxed up 94 percent less
time over the last few years
thread hijacking attempts doubled
compared to 2021. threat hijacking
another form of catfishing is when an
attacker compromises a victim's email
account and replies to a recent email
thread impersonating the victim by
hijacking an email thread adversaries
can trick a target's friends family even
co-workers into providing access to
sensitive information data or systems
creating a chain reaction with multiple
victims
extortion is a battle tested technique
that exerts pressure levers to inflict
maximum pain on a victim organization
and the latest scheme is involving
customers and business partners as pawns
extortion was the top impact observed in
2022 more than one quarter of attacks
involved some form of extortion
for the second year in a row
manufacturing was the most extorted
industry extortion accounted for 30
percent of incidents in manufacturing
and 27 percent in all Industries
even as the number of vulnerabilities
disclosed hit another record high the
proportion of weaponized exploits to
reported vulnerabilities has been
trending down
from 2018 to 2022 exploits relative to
vulnerabilities dropped by more than
nine percent
attackers have access to nearly 78 000
known exploits making it easier to use
an existing exploit left unpatched
rather than investing time and resources
into developing a new one
in 2022 X-Force observed several
incidents resulting from three to five
year old exploits so what can you do
use adversary simulation to understand
an attacker's view of both known and
unknown risks this can help
organizations take preventative measures
before an incident happens
take steps to protect yourself from
thread hijacking such as using strong
and unique passwords and enabling
multi-factor Authentication
for organizations that have a low
threshold for downtime they need to have
a proactive cyber security strategy
including active threat assessment
playbooks and other cyber range
activities
and remember
to operate under the assumption of
an assumed breach
assume an attacker already has access to
your environment and is moving around
be proactive not reactive
stop focusing on the perimeter start
focusing on detection and response
prioritize your security
and when